we got the story from the daily mail
multiple high-powered weapons are seized
at youtube star jake paul's
6.9 million calabasas mansion after fbi
agents
riding in military trucks swarmed the
property in connection to his arrest
for arizona mall riots as his
collaborators vegas home is also rated
i just got to show you these photos
because that's the gist of it right
check this out first let me let me read
they say a second fbi raid was also
conducted at a separate property
belonging to
fellow social media personality and
friend of paul armani izzati in las
vegas
the outlet said izadi was also arrested
during the looting in arizona
in june paul was charged with criminal
trespass and unlawful assembly by
authorities in scottsdale arizona
who say they were sent hundreds of tips
claiming paul was a participant in the
riot
the case against both paul and azadi was
later dropped by the city attorney
ahead of wednesday's raid by the fbi
in a statement the cotsdale scottsdale
police department said it is in the best
interest of the community to dismiss
misdemeanor charges without prejudice so
that a federal criminal investigation
can be completed
scottsdale retains the option to refile
charges depending on the outcome of the
federal investigation check this out
look at this
it looks like he's got two right there
he's got one right there
he's got another right here now i'm i'm
interested
why would they seize these they didn't
arrest anybody apparently well and
let me let me just get that straight so
if if they don't federally charge him
does that that means scottsdale can
actually
chart then charge him so they just
dropped it because the feds came in like
we're actually going to be charging
they're stepping out of the way like oh
okay yeah so i'll tell you right off the
bat for those just just popping in i'll
tell you what i think i think this is
the doj donald trump said we're coming
after you
we're coming after you 10 years for for
for vandalizing statues and federal
property 10 years
now now hold on jake paul's not going to
get 10 years he was trespassing and seen
you know in these riots
but it seems like law and order works
check it out man there was a poll from
gallup that was released today
and you know what it said what 81
percent of black americans
want the same level of policing in their
neighborhoods
or more yeah so the numbers actually 61
percent
want the same level of policing they're
satisfied
and it's and it's actually interesting
among the the
uh the latino community the hispanic
community uh is even more satisfied
but across the board the overwhelming
majority of americans
are satisfied with the amount of time
police spend patrolling their
neighborhoods in fact
20 percent of black americans want to
see more time spent placing their
neighborhoods
19 want to see less but that means we've
got a massive number of people
who do not agree with this defund
narrative with this abolish narrative
or with these protests the riots sorry
man
they are not popular so i'll tell you
what happens donald trump
he says we're coming for you did you did
you hear what he said earlier this
morning
uh on fox no i didn't catch that he said
black lives matter is a marxist group
which they've admitted well they're
openly a lot of the higher higher like
like high profile activist leaders are
definitely you know far left
what trump said through a marxist group
and if i'm wrong i'll lose an election
that's what he said he's won wow he's
he's laid his cards right on the table
that's why this story about jake paul
you know
like it like it like rung a bell or like
a light bulb popped up when i heard it
because they said it was connected to
the riots and i'm thinking here's what
happens the dude travels across state
lines
with some other buddy across the other
state lines nevada they go in riot
and now here's what i think i think the
doj was trying to figure out how can we
make sure everybody knows
that if you do this you're going to get
locked up
well you go after the highest profile
person guarantee
that all the news is going to be like
whoa what's going on with this guy jake
paul he's very famous got 20 million
subs
now he's getting his home rated and we
see these photos of rifles now
here's something i'm curious about why
are they seizing these rifles
i don't know is it because he can't have
them while charges are pending is it
because he couldn't legally
have him in the first place they didn't
arrest him but they didn't arrest him no
that they came and raided his home and
they seized a bunch of guns
could these guns be fake they take them
across straight lines maybe
yeah i don't know maybe they saw him in
a video because these guys are too
brazen
but i'm curious for two reasons i don't
like the idea of the state coming in
and seizing people's properties that's
not the state this is the feds the feds
right right well i mean i'm both i
should clarify i mean the colloquial
definition of the state okay state
authority
as like the full country yeah so these
are feds
coming in and taking his guns now that
i'm like
okay okay i mean we know he was rioting
so
this is this is not the mccloskeys right
the mccloskeys came out were eating
dinner and defending their property in
st
louis and the cops came and took their
guns that immediately was
made me angry like whoa whoa whoa right
this is different
this is a dude who i mean i don't even
know what this is i wonder how many
people watching can identify these these
weapons that are seen laying around it
says footage shows what appeared to be a
high-powered rifle
resting against the star's hot tub in
the backyard that appears in many
of his recent youtube videos i mean that
could be an air rifle
for all we know could be a prop i've
seen i've seen air rifles that look like
that also
but he's a youtuber these could be props
also true yeah but if they were why
would they seize them
i think dude had guns i'm curious about
the gun laws in california because in
calabasas my understanding is
california's fairly strict but
i don't know these are these are long
guns so it might might not be a big deal
it looks like a shotgun yeah it looks
like uh it's got a shotgun a couple
shotguns
this actually i can't tell what these
are i bet people watching can probably
spot them
instantly and know what they are but
they seized a bunch of weapons yeah but
check this out look at these guys man in
full
like look at this gear whoa this is this
is them going to his house we know that
i i mean yeah that's what it says look
several federal agents dressed in
tactical gear arrived in armored
vehicles after serving the youtube star
with a search warrant
bro you riot you know they're going to
come and lock you up
and i and i think i'm i'm not a fan of
using the law to make examples of people
because i think the law should be
applied equally
these these i really really don't like
it when you know judges are like well to
make sure no one ever commits a crime
we're going to give you a million years
or some nonsense doesn't seem fair
but i think they don't need to do that
they just need to
charge him federally and he'll get a
slap on the wrist to whatever degree
but everyone will know so they don't
they don't need to do anything harsh
now i see i see this uh this thing going
around like antifa
and blm uh protesters
no they're straight up rioters they're
posting these videos and pictures saying
please stop filming us please stop
taking pictures of us
we're getting arrested now so please
stop filming what we're doing
it's like no people are gonna film you
this is the information era
everyone has a phone they can just hit
you up take this this is why they attack
people
yeah you're right this is why they go
after andy no because
andy aggregates information on their
activities
and they're trying to suppress him the
amazing thing is how they
like the the amazing thing for those
that aren't familiar with andy no he's
like in my opinion the foremost expert
on the far left extremism
especially in the pacific northwest so
they call him
a white supremacist even though he's
he's a child of immigrants and he's
gay and a minority it's like uh
and now he's he's testified multiple
times yeah in front of like
congress you know up twice in the past
month i think you know
i gotta say that he is he's the
forerunner on what they're doing he's
from
portland he's watched it happen around
him as he
grew up there he's so brave so they
basically just go on and talk about
you know basically the same stuff we
already know that he got raided and he
was connected to
you know the riots so again simply put i
think they're making an example of him
but we'll see
they say in one shot from the scene in
la a long-barreled gun was spotted in
the backyard resting as a hot tub so you
get it
but the fbi announced during that that
testimony
that they have 300 domestic terror
investigations as a result of riots
attorney tells capital hearing on antifa
and now here's a quick little update as
well
multiple fires reported in downtown
portland parking garages last night
of course so so this so listen last
night was particularly crazy
yeah they saw some crazy stuff yeah they
were stabbing the tires
of that guy's car and then he speeds
through and runs like he's just ended
breaking the windshield
like they were oh yeah coming after that
guy
so you know don't finish don't finish he
someone actually parked a motorbike in
front of this truck so he couldn't go
anywhere he was coming to a stop
he was just driving down the street they
all kind of bombarded him and some dude
got in front of him with a mini bike
and dropped it down so he couldn't go
anywhere and then they started beating
the car
breaking the windshield and he just took
off and you just see sparks flying
because the mini the well it was like a
motorcycle it wasn't it was a dirt bike
that's what it was
and he just dragged it it's crazy
it's crazy man i i don't blame him at
all
i see all this stuff i see this poll
from gallup right
81 of black americans do not agree with
defund the police
they actually 20 want more cops then
there's another study that came out
that says you know how in 2016 in the
2015-16 cycle
journalists got it all wrong they they
stories were wrong they were mocking
trump they gave him a really low chance
of winning
and then after trump won they were all
like what did we get wrong we don't
understand
a new study came out that mapped
journalists on twitter
published by uh it was illinois uh i
think urbana champagne okay
and they found that it's worse it's
worse
well that's not surprising to me that i
mean it is surprising to me
really yeah because not you you'd think
check it out
in 2016 they got everything wrong okay
then
last year when i was talking to jack
dorsey he said
the same problem journalists on twitter
only follow
like leftists the liberal journals only
follow each other conservatives follow
both
but it's getting better he said well
jack you were wrong
wait hold on so you believed jack i did
okay all right i mean look
look i i you want to give people the
benefit of the doubt it's not that but
what
what's the benefit of him lying about
journalists getting things right or
wrong
uh i don't know maybe he just doesn't
know
anyway here's the point here's the point
multiple fires reported in downtown
portland parking garages and here's my
favorite bit
they say it's unclear what if any
connections the fires had to
to to each other or to protest that have
taken place near
in the at the nearby justice center and
federal courthouses for many nights
uh-huh okay you got riots going on
downtown for 70 days it's like it's like
69 days was last night tonight 70.
and then fires are started in multiple
buildings just near
it's insane to me no connection yeah
yeah but anyway come on
here's here's the ultimate point i'm
bringing this up is that
we've got these journalists in the
beltway in dc
who are actually in smaller bubbles this
time
than they were last time which means all
the news you're hearing
when you like turn on cnn and brian
stelter is like
it sounds like he's talking to the seven
people who still believe him
and you're like huh and you can't
imagine why they're getting it wrong
i think you know i think people have
broken out of this
the one of the ways i've described it in
the past is that you have this like
whirlpool
of fake news where all the journalists
are talking to each other and it's get
as you get closer to the center it's
spinning faster and faster because
they're sharing the same recycled story
and it's getting crazier and crazier
yeah and regular people are caught in
that as well but as it spins faster from
more and more fake news
regular people get thrown out you know
i'm one of them
exactly i was tossed out and i looked
and i'm like whoa i'm never jumping in
that whirlpool again you know
you know the gravitron is yeah that ride
where you slide
where it slides up as you're spinning
spinning and then you get stuck to the
wall yeah those are fun
and there have been you know instances
where people have been ejected from them
because it's spinning really fast
because there's some that are that are
like closed and there are some that are
open okay and yeah it spins so fast it
breaks and then you could get launched
out if it's spinning or actually here's
a better example you ever see the video
where the kids are on the the
what's that what's that thing called
it's the wheel it's like a playground
then it goes oh
no no no no the the centrifugal force
one where yes
it's small and you stand the name of it
you push what is i don't know what it's
called either
but anyway you don't see those anymore
man that's that's back from when we were
kids but there's a video you can watch
this they put a mini bike wheel
lay it down okay and then they got three
guys holding on and they speed the bike
up and then one dude
he like gets thrown backwards and it's
like flailing and it gets launched
straight out
okay that's what's happening to people
every day because the fake news is
getting crazier and crazier
we're at a point now where we can see we
can literally see jake paul rioting
and people are like i know that guy is
dude he's rioting
and then you have all this violence
going on and then they come to you and
they go
there are no riots antifa doesn't exist
nobody right peaceful protests there is
no war embossing say
i love that meme thanks for checking out
this clip from the tim cast irl podcast
we do the show
live monday through friday at 8 pm if
you want to catch the full show
tune in to this channel subscribe hit
the like button or
check us out on itunes and spotify and
we will soon have this podcast up for
free
on all podcast platforms thanks for
hanging out and we'll see you all in the
next episode